les manifestations contre la technologie
5g la cinquième génération de
télécommunications sans fil se
multiplient 6h ajoute un électrochoc en
bien qu'ils aient déjà et ans et c'est
la goutte qui va faire déborder le vase
pour beaucoup de gens en termes de
ressentir de symptômes mais la 5g c'est
pas la même bête en tout que je connais
des gens pour l'association canadienne
des télécommunications sans fil la cmj
est nécessaire pour répondre aux
demandes des consommateurs l'absence de
délai fait 6 litres et le développement
de plusieurs technologies comme les
voitures autonomes ou les réalités
virtuelles
s'il est la vitesse n'est pas
suffisamment grande
si la transmission la qualité
transmission n'est pas très grande
à ce moment là si vous l'avez regardé un
film tout en cours il ya un petit peu de
perturbations vous avez tous eu mal à la
tête mais les ondes de la 5g sont
beaucoup plus courte que celle du 4g il
faudrait donc multiplier les antennes
unir givors au lieu d'avoir 1200
antennes comme on à montréal en ce
moment il prend n'avoir 60000 les effets
thermiques de la scène j'ai se font
sentir sur les insectes mais ce sur la
santé humaine reste controversée ce
chercheur affirme que les risques sont
réels mais sont camouflés par
l'industrie
l'industrie a utilisé ce que
j'appellerais de la science de mighty
mouse pour convaincre le public qui
avait pas de danger
les effets des autres générations sont
déjà mesurées et détecter et confirmés
donc si on augmente les radiations les
effets vont empirer
alors que la ville de bruxelles arrêter
le déploiement du 5 g pour étudier les
risques
le chine travaille déjà aux si j'ai le
sac j'ai fait des us et désuet parce que
le spectre électromagnétique est limité
et que le supect qu'ils essaient
d'utiliser avec des singes et est
tellement inefficace qu'il faut se
rapprocher des gens à des très courte
distance
la réponse aux besoins de sociétés en
informations c'est la fibre optique
le déploiement de la 5g ne fait que
commencer avec un projet pilote à
montréal les opposants souhaiterait que
les municipalités impose un moratoire
sur cette technologie
qui émousse et par les fabricants de
téléphones mobiles ici michel marsolais
radio canada montréal